he's he's he's one of the best of all
time
you know made a couple great audibles
made a couple great throws
tough as hell i mean we hit him a few
times we didn't bother him one bit
that's john gruden talking about the guy
he wishes was on his team aaron rodgers
i know he has high praise for him we've
talked about him before i mean i know he
looks at him as being the greatest or
one of the greatest of all times and i
could just imagine that john gruden in
his own unique way how do you like that
um
we've already praised aaron rodgers he'd
be one of the superlatives for today if
we hadn't spent most of the first
segment talking about it but this is
where we go over the other superlatives
the the awards we want to hand out i'll
let you go first okay the first one i'm
going to chicago with the floor
d
yeah you like that
the saints yes it's not about their
offense anymore it's about their defense
right now and who's our coordinator uh
dennis allen thank you i messed that up
on the show last night so everybody can
uh understand what he's joking making
fun of me i couldn't i was like josh
allen jeff fallon i was saying all these
allen's names in my head i couldn't come
out with uh dennis but either way uh i
think that the big thing is from this
game i mean the new orleans saints are
just such a good well-rounded physical
football team and their defense just
wore down i don't want to say word down
they dominated the chicago bear offense
it wasn't a wear down what happened is
the bear's defense instead got wore down
on the other side because they were out
on the field every fourth play basically
but it all stemmed from that new orleans
defense you know i never at one point
thought really the saints were in danger
in this football game even when cordaro
patterson had the punt or the kick
return for the touchdown and i think
that gave the uh it made it 9-7 and and
the bears went up 10 to 10-9 at one
point um the way they were saying to run
the ball playing defense teddy
bridgewater taking care of the football
uh it is special and then their defense
causing fumbles uh as you're seeing if
you're watching on tv right near right
now with david montgomery fumbling
anthony miller the wide receiver at one
point caught a ball and took a hard hit
and he fumbled uh getting a sack here
they're a phenomenal phenomenal team let
alone the bears offense sucks okay and
there's no other way i could say it they
can't pass block they can't run block uh
the quarterback's not playing well and
the offensive game plans aren't good
dennis allen's going to mess around and
get himself head coaching consideration
he was in oakland and really who has
been successful in oakland in the past
however many years right so uh i i think
that this saints defense needs to be
taken seriously they still continue to
put the game plans together necessary to
score the points that they need and the
final score of this game not nearly
as indicative of what a butt whooping it
was yeah some garbage time touchdown
scored by the bears so the saints moved
to six and one and they're still waiting
for drew brees to come back he wants to
come back next week i was told a few
weeks ago the cardinals game is the
target but they got the cardinals then a
bye week and everything's going so well
why wait until after the bye week yeah
all right my first one and and i got to
give credit to michael david smith he
has invented a new statistic i mentioned
to it i saw it earlier you liked it i
like it you're the guy that's invented
the new defensive statistic the f up the
play right mds has what he calls the
double triple and it's amazing to me
because you would think that this
happens with some frequency and it
really doesn't where someone has a
hundred or more yards in any statistical
category it can be passing and rushing
it can be rushing and receiving it can
be return yardage right anything where
you get triple digits in any stat in two
different categories in the same game
lamar jackson
in just a season and less than a half
has four of them
a hundred plus yards passing a hundred
plus yards rushing for him that ties him
for second place all time
in only a season and a half he's tied
with russell wilson walter payton dante
hall great quick return back in the what
the decade and a half ago late 90s
and some guy named gary ballman has four
of them the leader is michael vick with
eight but lamar jackson's already
halfway there yes in a season and a half
he's gonna sail right by mike vick it's
just an amazing performance amazing
accomplishment for a guy who says he
hates running well he's getting it done
and he had another big day running the
football yesterday and they went to
seattle and they beat the seahawks at a
time when and big cat said this friday
maybe the ravens felt a little
fraudulent maybe that 4-2 record wasn't
as as
as honest of a reflection of what the
team really is to go to seattle and win
against a team that was firing on all
cylinders and and to really kind of
out-rustle wilson yeah and russell
wilson's own building yeah it was pretty
impressive for lamar jackson it was
impressive he's in that mvp discussion
now he he is he should be i mean for
what he's doing for that team i mean mvp
yeah i mean they you know i mean the
offense they're running and the talent
they have on the offensive side of the
ball doesn't work unless you got lamar
jackson and then really the to me one of
the big moments and this is you're
watching this fourth and two touchdown
uh this was a huge changing point of the
game because seattle missed a long field
goal it gave the ravens the short field
and they went off the field on third
down and lamar jackson showed some real
fire like i've never seen him be like
that he was yelling at john harbaugh
like go for it and john harbaugh changed
his damn mind called a timeout and they
went for it and they scored a touchdown
and the game was really over from that
point but the ravens yeah they're not
going to win a lot of games sexy because
they're defense they run the ball that's
the way they play but either way he was
phenomenal one last thing about that
double triple yeah
christian mccaffrey's got one right you
would think he had more marshall falcon
and roger craig the only guys who had a
thousand yards rushing and a thousand
yards receiving or more in a season zero
for each they never did the double
triple wow
yeah it's a fascinating status
forgiveness way to go mds yep we'll get
that and uh my my and what i'm gonna
call mine the fup f-u-he just be careful
yeah just be careful all right i won't
say it anymore okay here we go welcome
to hollywood award goes to jaylen ramsey
welcome to this land of the stars and
the hollywood hills jaylen ramsey i mean
jalen ramsay doesn't play football for
three weeks because he had a bacchiotomy
okay
and
either way he looked very healthy on
sunday and his presence was felt really
from get-go in that football game the
rams dominated the atlanta falcons uh
the atlanta falcons stink we know that
but the rams defense dominated uh the
falcons offense where matt ryan was
under duress but the big thing is jalen
ramsey after not playing three weeks oh
yeah just go over there and cover one of
the freakiest guys we've seen in the
history of the nfl his name's julio
jones no problem then you talk about
like the attitude he brings to your team
look at this i mean putting a hit on
devante freeman making him fumble that's
what's special about jalen ramsey he's
one of the most physical corners we've
seen uh he really plays the position
almost like a safety but then the
ability to bump and run julio jones be
all over him he's just a special special
player and the rams are of course got
back on track after a rough few weeks
looked good yesterday gurley had the
touchdown catch i'm not giving up on the
rams you know the rams are still a team
that i think is still very very
dangerous in the nfc just again they
missed an easy or not an easy but a
definitely makeable game-winning field
goal against the seahawks up there you
know the game seven and seven seven
against the 49ers and it's third and
goal at the one foot line and they don't
get in on third and fourth so they're
they're still a quality football team i
think they reminded us of that yesterday
and they're going to be more quality
with number 20 at corner playing
shutdown and now wade phillips can have
fun with the rest of the guys it was the
ultimate get right game though for the
rams against the falcons team that is
just a shell of what it was only three
years ago when they won the nfc and were
up 28-3 in the super bowl but uh i i
you know and
this is supposed to be about the good
not the bad but i just can't figure out
where the falcons are going to see a
shot of the stadium in the second half
nobody nobody was there yet and why
would you go why would you go watch that
team play but the rams are look they're
four and three now with the seahawks
losing they've narrowed that gap a
little bit and then they're in that spot
in their in their schedule where they
can start to rack up some wins and yeah
they made the bold move for jalen ramsey
who knows how it's going to play out
over the long haul but at least for now
they started to move in the right
direction they got the bengals in london
coming up this week so kudos to the rams
so far for ending that losing streak and
getting themselves pointed in the right
direction again all right uh for me this
is the if we didn't have bad luck we'd
have no luck at all award because they
have no luck but they had some good luck
yesterday in the indianapolis colts
right yes and and look
this was a huge game for the colts they
they were coming off of their buy we
kind of forgot about the colts they beat
the chiefs and we forgot about them yeah
because houston beat the chiefs and we
crowned we were like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you know this is the afc
south championship round game one
one of these two teams is winning that
division the jaguars are yeah they're
three and four and they're still lurking
but i feel like it's going to come down
to the texans and the colts and they
they they did what they had to do and
you know we talked about this last night
on football night in america when
the texans had that fourth down play and
they tried to go back to the same well
they went back to last week inside just
from the other side of the formation
right he moved him to the left side
instead of the right side and darius
slender told me
you take away their best player yeah
that's what you do that's what the
coaches told him to do and you know the
defensive coaching in in key moments
it's not like they shut them down no but
in key moments of work but they did get
a little bit of good luck yeah that
desean watson play where he was in the
grass sure that was a little bit of a
quick whistle that was or maybe things
would have been a little different for
guys like desean watson but mike i think
you you know you hit the nail on the
head the defense was the difference in
this football game with some of their
stops and especially early on you know
if you remember early on the the texans
got the ball with two short fields off
of turnovers by the colts and the colts
defense held them to field goals where
the game could have been 14-7 something
like that houston texans and said it was
7-6 and really that was the difference
of the game you know the the texans
scored field goals the colts scored
touchdowns and he looked up and it was
21-9 and the texans were having to play
catch-up football uh but yeah the colts
we can't forget about them because they
do they're well coached on defense frank
reich i think is one of the more
creative play callers in all of football
and we saw another weapon pascal in the
passing game other than ty hilton eric
ebron's coming we know they're going to
run the ball and uh yeah we got to make
sure we keep the cults very relevant
because they are very relevant in the
afc all right that wraps up the
superlative
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports